where I want to start the lesson
is as we've done a few times already
back here in this syllabus I think it's
so important we always return to
thinking about like where are we up to I
think it's just a really good habit
especially you know uh for those many
students including potentially you Ryan
if you go to university
um after school I've actually just
started working part-time at a
university just last week and so it's
just reminded me one of the primary
things that you you need to do as you
head into that space is learn to be much
more independent about your learning
you're certainly much more independent
now than you were when you started high
school but there's another step to go
like can you imagine if no one ever
marked a role if no one um if no one
sent letters if you weren't doing work
they just let you fail and then you have
to pay again and enroll in the subject
another time uh that amount of
Independence is great but it also
requires new skills and doing things
like this looking at the syllabus and
saying yes what is it that we're
supposed to be learning can I take
responsibility for my own in progress is
a really good habit to get into so let's
just review and see what we're up to in
this V 1.3 section of three-dimensional
vectors right
so what have we done here well so far we
have let me use orange
um we've used Cartesian coordinates in
two and three-dimensional space yes
absolutely
um just last lesson on Wednesday we
recognized and we found the equations of
spheres which if you use a vector
equation the vector equation of a sphere
is the same as the vector equation of a
circle which is kind of nice it extends
very easily
we've used Vector equations of Curves in
two or three dimensions involving a
parameter do you remember like what
what's the usual symbol we've been
putting on our parameter so far
yeah it tends to be Lambda occasionally
when we have a question that requires a
second parameter like a second there's
another line and a hazard in parameter
we might use mu but really it doesn't
matter these are just conventions right
so we've been we've been introduced to
that I'm going to skip a point you'll
see why in a second understand and use
the vector equation R equals a plus
Lambda B of a straight line through
points A and B so we've actually done
this a few times right if I give you any
two arbitrary points A and B we know
that a is called the what is it again
starts with a starts with a P
which which Vector is it yeah it's the
position Vector right we know what that
part is and then the the B Vector in
this case what do we call that not the
position Vector it's the
Direction yeah it tells you exactly
which way you're facing
um so that you can get along the line
and then the Lambda what that tells you
is
um you know how do you how far along the
line do you want to go right so say for
example a Lambda of zero is the point on
the line that is the position Vector
right and then a Lambda of one takes you
further in the direction of the
direction vector and then Lambda of two
goes even further and lamber of negative
values goes the other way okay
so um we've introduced the rest of those
bits there sorry did you have a question
yeah a few times like I just heard
something
um now just notice this next one it's
really interesting to me right most of
the syllabus you can see it says like
you do things right it's like I want you
to know a formula or I want you to use a
skill this next dot Point here I'm just
going to highlight it
um it's unusual you don't see these
kinds of things very often and hopefully
you can remember to when I did it it
says make connections in two Dimensions
between the vector equation or a line
that we just talked about and Y equals
MX plus C now do you remember this we're
comparing uh gradient intercept form and
saying oh what gradient inset form is
doing is saying hey get onto the line
like the y-intercept is a point on the
line and then just face in a certain
direction and that's all gradient is
right so position Vector Direction
Vector are really
um I was going to say parallel and I
didn't mean the pun but they're quite
synonymous with this uh form of a
straight line in two Dimensions that
we've been familiar with for years so
that's why I made a big deal about it
because the syllabus says make the
connection right
and then most of the stuff that the rest
you can see there is just a bit of a
list it's like determine this determine
that um so these are the kinds of things
that the exercises have been working
through right
now I said um the thing that I was gonna
I skipped over a bit right and it's here
I'm going to highlight in a different
color let's use blue it says up in the
third dot point it says determine uh
corresponding Cartesian equation in the
two-dimensional case where possible now
we haven't really explicitly done this I
may have assigned a question or two that
asks you to do this but we haven't
actually done it together and because
this is quite an important idea that's
actually what I want to spend in today's
lesson working on before we have a look
at next week's stuff which will round
out the topic and next week's stuff is
actually up here see it says proved
geometric results in the plane and
construct proofs in three dimensions as
well that's that's the exercise we
skipped over so that's what we'll be
doing next week just before Easter okay
so like I said this bit that's
highlighted in blue that's what we're
going to do today just before I leave
off this syllabus do any of you have any
questions or things you want to clarify
as we're having a look at what the
syllabus tells us we should be learning
at the moment or does it seem okay to
you
okay happy times well in that case you
can go ahead and make I I don't have a
nice uh flowery title for this I was
just like what are we working with today
I don't know lines and curves when
looking at their Vector equations so I
call the vector equations and lines and
curves now the important part that you
need to probably jot down before we lose
it off of the screen is um these two
equations that I've I've provided for
you here now they're provided in
component form I've actually come to
realize this I I'd actually forgotten it
um from the last time I taught vectors
and and spending this time with you guys
has reminded me I don't like component
form that much right I actually prefer
column form much easier I find it more
natural and intuitive to read however
you gotta you gotta know it morning Sean
you've got to be able to translate back
and forth between the different forms
um and so I'm I think it's important
that I I sort of give you questions in
component form just like the textbook
does so that you are familiar yeah right
we call this representational fluency
there's different representations and
you want to float back and forth between
them quite comfortably and um and not
feel like oh one's my favorite I only
use that one um you don't want to do
that you want to be good with all of
them
so we've got two equations here can you
guys go ahead and tell me what what are
these equations like the the question
doesn't tell you what what do the
equations represent
okay so line industry is very close
um we do definitely have a line over
there on the left hand side by the way
can you tell me how how could you tell
that it was aligned what what sort of
gave it away
yeah so hopefully you recognize those
two bits we looked at before right there
is a oh that's not what I wanted to do I
wanted to highlight there's a position
Vector hanging out here at the front and
then that parameter is multiplied by a
direction Vector so you're like oh I I
know what this does right now on the
right hand side
um it's very much like a sphere but
there's a clue that tells you it's it's
not quite a sphere
um what's the clue that gives away that
it's not actually a sphere even though
it's very closely related
so
uh yeah there's no um
yeah yeah nicely spotted so because
there is no um K value there's no Third
Dimension
um what you've got here is the the sort
of two spots uh sorry the two
coordinates of the center of the circle
um the circle not a sphere is what sort
of gives away this whole question is
two-dimensional at the moment
um as a point of um interest though not
that we're looking at at the moment this
is this is not a sphere it's a it's a
circle in two Dimensions but if I did
ask you to put this into three
dimensions you wouldn't get a sphere you
would actually still get a circle but
because like the Zen axis can do
anything yeah you just go straight up
and down so in fact what you've got is a
cylinder of well hold it a hollow
cylinder with no top and bottom it just
goes infinitely up and down in the Z
Direction so that's a bit weird we're
not looking very much it's not really
within the scope of the course we're
just looking at the syllabus just now
but if if you were asked like what is
what is this thing right if you wanted
to know it's a cylinder that just goes
on forever
okay so yeah sorry what did you say
only in the gay Vector oh okay could
there be a k component in the v Vector
um the answer is yes there could be and
I suppose it's kind of um I haven't
hopefully there's enough context here to
tell you that this is in a we're
considering in a two-dimensional space
because yeah or like if that well that's
not what I wanted to draw if that V
Vector indeed was x y z remember it's a
it's a variable right this Vector can be
can take on different values if there
was an XYZ there and you only got an i
and a j I guess that implies there's a
zero K there which is which I guess is
the cylinder situation right however
given that everything else is
two-dimensional here it is I think a
reasonable conclusion to draw excuse me
that we're playing in the land of two
Dimensions we're on a plane okay but but
really good point actually and I've I
have left it ambiguous to be fair okay
all right so now that we know what the
two equations represent let's actually
think about what this question is asking
right it says find the Cartesian
equations so again just scrolling back
just a little bit see there in blue
determine a corresponding Cartesian
equation that's what we need to be able
to do in the two-dimensional case which
is why I've given us this and then what
I want us to do is find the points of
intersection between the line and the
circle if indeed there are multiple
points there could of course be just one
if the line is tangent to the circle
there could be none as well like it
could just fly off and not intersect but
as a spoiler yes they do intersect and
we're just going to try and find out
where okay
so let me just pause for a minute
um have a look at the line the circle
which do you think is easier to find the
uh Cartesian equation for what do you
reckon
yeah the second one I agree um the
circle is actually very easy to work out
because for a Cartesian equation of a
circle all we need is a center and a
radius and you can more or less read
that off of the vector equation of a
circle right what's the center we're
looking for
very good so let's let's jot that down
so this is uh This Is Us doing part A at
the moment so the circle
we'll have a centaur 1 8 exactly as you
said
you do have to be careful right because
when you have a look there it's take
away the whole Vector so really it is
take away I plus 8j and that's where you
get the one and the eight from great
there's the center what's the radius
yeah this is this is so sneaky right
this is this gets the fluency thing
right so we're like ah okay read the
equation the vector equation says the
distance the magnitude of this Vector is
root through 13.
um and so that that distance that is by
definition the radius the reason you're
thinking of 13 is because when we write
the Cartesian equation in a second
what's on the right hand side of the
Cartesian equation
yeah it's r squared so we will get a 13
in a second right so Center and radius
can you guys go ahead can you just tell
me can you read it out what is the
equation that I want
the minus final squared
um 10 plus y minus able squared equals
13. fantastic okay well done so it's
it's Pythagoras isn't it it's uh the sum
of the squares of the two shorter sides
and then you've got the sum of sorry the
square of the hypotenuse on the right
hand side okay